hey brooklyn nine nine i'm ready to
season finale of season two
hey hey look full length watch along as
we sync with the time code over our
patreon page master thanks to all become
super checks your support means a lot uh
if you can't show your support or
patreon your support by leaving a like
and also subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
the next one is up then boys the prepper
thanks all the help boys
and you're good boys
let's do this
can we at least have five minutes to say
a proper goodbye
whatever that this machine is the best
restaurant in brooklyn
thank you for your service okay
squad salute
yeah they're ready to go
you can take her away now
[Music]
i think we handled that with dignity
free candy
[Applause]
why don't they just let them take the
candy in the first place i know why
they're just gonna throw all that out i
bet someone's doing inventory i'll never
forget we were so psyched in high school
to find out we had vending machines [ __ ]
was crazy and all boys high school
that's exciting all boys and a vending
machine last week he walked into a
government building and stole a computer
containing over 100 000 social security
numbers my ci says that tonight
augustine will be handing off the laptop
to a buyer from china aka the land of
dragons
peralta and santiago will tell augustine
boyle and diaz will join them in a
surveillance van in the immortal words
of amy santiago
girlfriend please
did i do something to you are you mad is
this because i brushed all the crumbs
off your desk what no i don't care about
that
do you know where they are
remember when you told me that you
didn't want to day cops
that really bummed me out mom
you know we're professionals that's all
i want for us to be professional we're
in agreement it will be good and
professional
a plus
madeleine wunsch is making me head of
public relations for the nypd i'm being
forced out of the nine-nine i don't wish
to make a big deal of it so please limit
your reactions to one second go why
a mutual friend told me madeline wrote a
letter to the mayor telling him it was a
mistake she apparently called her now
boss a quote simpering buffoon but i
need you to find that letter that's
illegal are you with me oh hell yeah i'm
turning my phone into airplane mode oh
gina
i know you don't like anyone wishing you
a happy birthday so
crappy day to you still too much
you were obviously trying to get me to
go to a surprise party did marcus put
you up to this
news crazy talking we just need to be
there exactly 9 45 pm not a minute
earlier also there's a particular door i
want to enter through
[Laughter]
augustine has the laptop with him we
should just arrest him right here no the
buyer's the bigger caller we got to
follow him in and wait for the handoff
okay if you're going in i've heard this
place has an amazing bone marrow custard
not that i've ever had a bad one
wait we look like cops we're never gonna
blend in dressed like this
well scully let's sports coat back there
but it'll never fit jake's athletic body
unless no i don't want to do that you
have to what do you have to do don
john's in it
oh yeah motion my forearms ah it's so
weird wearing rose's jacket
johnny and i just got engaged and this
is where our first date was yeah it
would mean so much to dora and me
i would have made a reservation but
i didn't know if she was gonna say yes
no i love how nervous you were you
little goose
thank you so much for waiting your table
is almost ready great
sorry about springing the engagement and
romantic stuff on you no no no that was
great i mean that's what got us in here
cheat kiss was a bit much very wet i
don't know what to tell you dora is
sloppy
well a lot of people think grackles are
uh just a common bird up here but you
know what on the west coast they don't
get grackles can you give some more info
you have got to know the difference
between your water purpose
snake bird and a swamp hog a lot of
people don't know they're all the same
bird enlighten us my guy the ones that
sound like rihanna kind of when they
sing i'm not familiar with who that is
they're like
that sounds like that might be a ghost
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got the letter well done now get me
madeline and a bucket of water it's time
to melt a witch
jesus
just get off my donut already don't
lightly boil or you will be eating your
bone marrow custard through a straw
that's exactly how you're supposed to
eat bone marrow no
all right there's a party i can't give
you details all i can say is i know you
and i know you'll have a good time you
knew me you'd know i hate surprise
parties so hey clearly you don't know me
at all
champagne and oysters you really
shouldn't have guys it's a special night
oh geez we first met five years ago
but we don't count it because i was
dating a speedboat model at the time
anyways about a year ago we bumped into
each other at a bar and
we haven't been able to keep our hands
off each other since so how did you know
she was the one oh i'd love to answer
that
whenever i look at her face and the
attached physique and you
uh he makes me laugh
no one else's opinion who i care about
more than her so
okay so enough chit-chat let's see the
ring
she has gigantic fingers
that the ring i got would never have fit
on her fingers because they are that of
a giant being
person
i'd like to talk about my promotion very
well but first how do i know you're not
wearing a wire
i need to pat you down if you must
good luck on your wedding guys oh have
fun on your honeymoon we will we're
going to waco texas
[Laughter]
romance
this is so funny why isn't he making the
handoff oh crap he saw us
oh
oh hey we were just
looking for a place to uh boink
yep
really engaged kids
enjoy
good good good good kept our cover in
tech nice work good professional
thinking out there very quick very
professional detective detective
back on the case
nice
profession they just had sets
they got told
amy and i kissed
what
to keep our cover from being blown we
didn't have a choice
tell me everything
in high school i played daddy warbucks
and annie becca merse played annie and
we were supposed to hug on stage at
first that seemed like nothing too but
by opening night we were full-on making
out as daddy warbucks
the audience was not on board nope
nope
how did you get this gina and terry got
it you grackle it doesn't matter how i
get it sorry sir didn't realize that was
how you wanted to play it
so you've got an audience for this
little stunt as well who wouldn't want
to see a man fight a crocodile
[Laughter]
give me my precinct back it's not that
simple i can't just reverse your
promotion
you have until tomorrow
oh god
[Laughter]
we are police colleagues you're under
arrest this is a work event
[Laughter]
all right there's only one way out of
this for me it's got to get super cruel
prepare to have your physical flaws
pointed out amy talking about your tall
butt and your weird elbow oh no before
we go in remember you have to pretend to
be surprised how's this
oh my god it's so much worse than i
imagined
the energy was great that was lovely
what's going on i rented this entire bar
so you and i could celebrate with no
people anywhere near it you have so much
money
it really must
it's all charles's idea
oh
oh
never call me roro again oh but i will
i've earned this
happy b day row row
[Music]
oh boy welcome madeline have you thought
things over i know buddy but first how
do i know you're not wearing a wire
[ __ ] i want it every time eight
minutes and counting you should go ahead
and show that letter to the commissioner
and let him fire you i'll deny i wrote
it it will take months to authenticate
which will give me plenty of time to
make some personnel changes around here
there's an opening for a detective down
in brighton beach no no
santiago would be a great fit for pelham
bay no and peralta
your little pet project
i'm gonna ship him off to staten
island don't be a davidson no
looks like you've got a decision to make
raymond what are you gonna do
squad if i could have your attention
please no
no
i'm being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately what the
hell i don't understand what the hell
why are you doing this what the hell
it has been a pleasure to have worked
alongside all of you for the past 21 and
a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the best
years of my career i don't know this is
new mm-hmm every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
sir
i'm coming with you thank you gina i'm
also coming not necessary
that's how you old nap
i don't know i'm still in shock
you i'm basically handling it the way i
dealt with my dad leaving just
repressing the hell out of it hug it out
so a lot of change around here huh say
some other things
go forth
hey jake the new captain's here
no
james spader
temporary will ferrell i know you're sad
but let's do our best to make a good
first impression here smart good call
jake you'll be upfront
[Music]
okay
here we go
of course screw that of course i'm just
playing the next episode and then
calling it quits once i see the face
i can't afford to wait anymore no not a
whole week
for you b99 fans you have to wait a
whole three years yeah
it took extra long rigs between seasons
that was one of the funniest brooklyn
nine-nine episodes man that was
hilarious and heartfelt it's like they
have to write them to make sure they're
extra funny so people will come back the
following season yes you don't have to
make any episodes funny except the
premiere and the finale yeah just like
walking dead that's where they make the
first and last grip
first 10 minutes last 10 minutes
yeah yeah good formula it works because
you guys at home when they start
promoting brooklyn nine nine season
three you're like you know that was
freezing finales these dudes that was
pretty choice that was funny it was
funny as heck it was funny that was
really funny that was genuinely like
that was hysterical everyone was great
everyone yeah and a lot of great little
payoffs to each different story yeah man
even twists and turns along the way that
whole like bit because there's always
been something kind of um
sexually awkward
about
lunch yes
yeah
your sexual tension yeah watch her
frisking him
it's just such a random what he is what
do you get out of this what is this what
purpose does this serve for you like she
wants him
i mean it's funny because he established
that right yeah yeah yeah she wanted him
and there's that i i admire that they've
held on to that because it is such like
a you know because the chief is gay like
there's so it takes on a strange
additional layer that i appreciate it's
ambiguous in an odd funny though yeah um
damn gave up his position so he didn't
have to separate the rest of the family
yeah see i at first i thought everybody
was gonna walk out with gina but
but yeah nah man jerry maguire that's
right
you had me
at hello
and then uh amy and jake though the big
highlight here they do have amazing
chemistry they do they are hot they are
hot
they're hot even when they're awkward
with each other i gotta find a person
who looks at me the way how jake looks
at amy
are you listening to me miss future mrs
alba oh
study up got your cat right here start
watching andy sandberg's face
start taking notes from watching look at
me the way andy sandberg looks at
melissa
vacuum what's her name
melissa the vacuum
yeah yeah
yeah they're great together they're
awesome and uh gina and terry oh it's
only let's say everything was funny
everything was rock solid comedy great
and yeah you know character comedy
physical comedy
banter based wordplay because there's a
little bit of every kind of comedy in
this episode yeah my favorite kind of
comedy is when they're trying to like
cover up yeah high stakes
oh quick gotta make a quick move i gotta
come here give me a kiss this is a work
event it's
yeah and even i mean even though this
wasn't even the most like uh heavily
engaged like the criminal element has
been i too like that they just basically
made friends with their mark
yeah and all that stuff and like yeah
they catch them by that but that's not
even the real point of it all but it was
made to support them talking about why
they like each other absolutely and i
thought they played that moment really
well where they each transition out of
trying to come up with something and
just say something real
you know
let's improv something to the top of
your intelligence ah you really make me
laugh i i trust you implicitly
learn to have a moment like that in your
life i
can't
okay
don't worry it'll happen we'll kiss
on camera
you're talking about you and i oh no
sorry
find it with someone else okay sorry
yeah i'll get out of here
go find it right now
don't come back until you found it bring
a camera would you
vlog it
yeah put it up on the second channel
i'm i don't know what's out here i know
it's just so graceful there's this great
great reveal with boyle and rose's
birthday nick cannon holding it down as
the cameo guy yeah he's like the
post-credits scene that remains a
post-credits scene in every episode he's
always here to be like hi i'm nick
cannon i'm charming that's my scene
[Laughter]
no this is not character man like it's
the best recurring star role ever the
relationship has evolved to this point
we're just renting out restaurants for
her yeah and i'm like i still have no
clue what your relationship is like all
happened off-screen yes
okay this is not a character
which which the more that persists just
the funnier that becomes to me i don't
even think it's supposed to be a joke i
don't think it is supposed to be a joke
i just find it funny
because also i mean like as nick cannon
you have to be aware of like what limbo
state that puts your celebrity status in
because it's like okay they cared enough
to get recognizable me nick cannon
however they only call me in for like an
hour's worth of shooting yeah to
basically be a prop for the other
characters
but uh but yeah good job on nick cannon
what do you think the new captain is
that's a great question
uh rob riggle what if they come back and
it's just uh
it's just
i forgot something yeah
i mean that was what i was ex
that was what i was
expecting had they actually maybe shown
it and if they chose not to i'm guessing
it's some kind of fun casting
and i like how he actually got like
something really sincere and emotional
at the end
yeah that was a beautiful moment this
that was a good theme this episode of of
like learning to let your walls down
i'm your wonder why oh yeah
today was gonna be the day that they're
gonna give it back to you
by now you should somehow realize what
you gotta do
i don't believe in anybody feels the way
i do about you now
yeah cause there are many things
yeah
because maybe
you're gonna be the one that saves me
better not demonetize them
[Music]
we better make our money before these
guys get rich off of oasis
so uh
that joke makes no sense you'll know
that we cut that out
why is there a weird skipper
claimed for some [ __ ] today
that was good though that was a good
rendition i think that that is worthy if
somebody wanted to rip it like i used to
with music on youtube you know just the
audio put it on your ipod listen to it i
wouldn't blame them we're good duet you
used to i still do that i still do
everyone's like just use your spotify
that you pay 10 bucks a month for
and i go oh yeah
you have a spotify you pay 10 bucks a
month for it
i didn't even think you had a spot i do
i forget i do oh well you can write it
off still so
i can yeah it's an entertainment company
you know
your podcast and stuff you could
theorize that you know or or you know if
the irs came and grilled you you could
be like well you know what he has 10
bucks a month that you know what is this
you claimed it for 12 months out of the
year that's 120 120 what are you doing
that's 20 thousand dollars you're not a
musician what are you doing and there's
podcasts on there there are people who
talk about marvel movies on spotify joe
rogers is spotify he's concert reviewing
martial
marvel movies and misinformation
i'm gonna randomly say some racial stuff
that's great
or you could get on title title's free
now
nah nah i don't i don't want to pay for
youtube right now that much
uh yeah youtube red all that money goes
to them
i think youtube has one of the better
compensation plans
certainly better than i hear spotify is
guys what do you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
let's do a patron of the day shout out
scuba steve we're going undercover and
if there's anybody i don't know we're
not doing that we're not doing it i want
you to shout out scuba steve and your
nick off from an impression please
oh goodness
i feel a little on the spot
scuba steve
you
your masculinity
frankly makes me uncomfortable
i would
i would watch you chop down a tree with
your bare hands
and rub redwood oil all over your
pectoral muscles
your beard
could keep me warm in the winter months
i would write a survival guide based on
you
you're the manliest man in our patron as
as i go further i'm losing it and and
now all can think of his h john benjamin
which i could do probably more uh
reliably on a longer
that's not what i wanted
that's right
i didn't want it you requested nick off
let me get in the mustang
my wife is megan mullally
we make butter together in the woods
cause you're [ __ ] you're making it about
you love horror movies and the greatest
horror
i can imagine
is being without you
in my life
looking at your instagram page and
wondering how many police officers you
have thwarted with your graffiti tagging
ways and if you would
draw a mural of me
in the nude
laid out across a bare-skinned road
that's good thanks that's that's for you
thoroughly satisfied
all right now i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
listen to like just a bunch of more
hours of nick offerman so that the next
one is
not even gonna know which one to shoot
when you're doing stand-up you're gonna
be like oh crowd's not laughing time to
whip out the offer
what's the deal
with it all right guys i got nick off
for men doing slime all right guys
now let's and now i got h john benjamin
doing nick
[Music]